she was my best friend she was my soul
mate she was very supportive she was
loving she was in a wheelchair yeah she
never once mourned about her illness it
was barely a month ago that Teresa
Simpson died her husband says the time
it took for an ambulance to arrive when
she fell ill at home is to blame 16
hours and 45 minutes I waited I had to
wait and he only came the second time
because I've hung him out of ring and
bats and my wife was lifeless 100 I
believe that if they got to my wife in
six out in within the six hours say from
three to nine o'clock my wife would
still be here now she would not be she
wouldn't I'm 100 that she would still be
here today because she would have got
the hell
in a statement Yorkshire Ambulance
Service offered Mr Simpson their sincere
condolences our patient relations team
they said has received correspondence
from him raising concerns about our
response to this incident they will
liaise directly with Mr Simpson about
specific details relating to this
Teresa died here and Matthew praised the
medical staff who tried to save her life
Health officials say as many as 500
people a week are dying across the
country as a result of delays in
emergency care and they say these are
not short-term issues caused by covid or
a bad flu season but a long-standing
problem that is blighting the NHS every
winter
foot NHS England disagrees we don't
recognize those figures and I think you
need to be extremely careful when you
look at the what are called excess
mortality figures if if you look and
make international comparisons you'll
find that many many Health Systems as
they're coming out of the pandemic are
seeing higher levels of mortality than
you would traditionally expect so the
same is that is the case in Germany and
Italy and Spain I think it probably is
fair to say that certainly talking to
Frontline staff talking to Frontline
Chief Executives this does feel like
it's the most significant degree of
pressure that we Face
the ambulance delays the gridlock at a e
the staff shortages come as industrial
unrest continues
we cannot go on like this we can't be
sitting here next year saying well this
is even tougher than last year January
is our toughest month the idea that we
can then take two days of nurses strikes
two days of ambulance down strike on top
of all of this without there being major
implications for patients well you know
it's it it's a fantasy there will be
more harm there will be more risk and
it's families up and down the country
who'll be facing that
we both knew she was on boratan because
of a mayotonic dystrophy but no I'm
sorry to say but she should never have
been left like that and she died to be
left to Die the way she did
Greg Milam Sky News Hull